et des services saturé moins de
personnel liée à la restriction à des
restrictions budgétaires et par
conséquent des patients moins bien
soignés les urgentistes ont tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé en entamant un
mouvement de grève il ya six mois et
depuis plus de la moitié des urgences
public de france a rejoint la
mobilisation et pour désamorcer est la
crise la ministre des solidarités de la
santé agnès buzyn a présenté hier une
série de mesures ont des briefs et
annonce avec vous bernard landais
bonsoir vous êtes le secrétaire force
ouvrière au centre hospitalier françois
quesnay de mantes-la-jolie vous êtes
également le secrétaire départemental
adjoint est de force ouvrière avant de
vous donner la parole nicolas landry
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78 que
faut-il retenir nicolas de ces annonces
de la ministre
et bien comme vous l'avez dit que c'est
pour vraiment répondre à ce mouvement
social que la ministre des solidarités
et de la santé agnès buzyn ap a annoncé
ce lundi 9 septembre lors d'une
conférence de presse au ministère un
pacte de refondation d urgence ce plan
sera financé à travers une enveloppe de
750 millions d'euros un financement et
une mise en oeuvre des dispositifs
prévus sur trois ans écoutez la ministre
agnès buzyn nous avons voulu nous
appuyer sur ces expériences de terrain
pour proposer un plan d'action global
qui va donner à chaque territoire à
chaque établissement
ces leviers d'action des expériences de
terrain issu d'un rapport 1 c'est ce que
dit la ministre
ce plan se décline en douze mesures à la
fois en amont et en aval des urgences le
plat principal annoncé la mise en place
du saas en temps des services d'accès
aux soins
un service d'appels ou de prise de
contact en ligne auprès d'un
professionnel de santé pour conseiller
et orienter vers la structure de santé
adapté une plateforme pour désengorger
les urgences elle sera opérationnelle à
l'été 2020 après une concertation avec
les professionnels de santé
on a ensuite le développement de
protocoles de coopération
l'idée c'est d'assurer la prise en
charge de patients par des
professionnels de santé qui ne sont pas
médecins s'est par exemple la
prescription de médicaments ou des
examens médicaux réalisés par des
pharmaciens
on peut aussi prendre l'exemple d'une
entorse à la cheville pris en charge par
un
kinésithérapeute au lieu d'aller aux
urgences enfin prends l'exemple aussi
des conditions de travail des personnels
des urgences qui font l'objet de mesures
spécifiques c'est à dire l'optimisation
de leur temps de travail le renforcement
de leurs compétences
c'est le cas notamment pour les
infirmiers qui pourraient avoir plus
d'autonomie dans leurs pratiques au sein
des urgences et une revalorisation
salariale
on peut aussi mentionner la construction
de nouvelles maisons médicales de garde
le renforcement des consultations sans
rendez-vous ou encore un parcours
spécifique pour les urgences destinés
aux personnes âgées des mesures
destinées à améliorer l'activité des
urgences et à apaiser le conflit social